hello folks how's everybody I hope
you're doing fine today I want to remind
everyone that we have a conference
coming up in the 4th of April okay
that's gonna be in Sokka some yeah
Zambia so if you plan to go get your
bags ready and buy your tickets can't
make your reservations second thing I
want to remind people of you know we
have a book with up loaded the other day
you can download it for free ok and it
brings you up to speed up the Rope
hypothesis and one of the things we're
asking people whoever has a different
language has another mother tongue or
whatever mother language and which is to
translate it to his or her mother tongue
to contact us at cocka cocka doodle comm
and what we can do is send you a word
file and you pay around with it and then
send it back and we you know you can
send it back as a PDF file or send it
back as a word file and we'll upload it
and give you credit for it ok ok so have
you said that let's get on with the
subject matter today it's gonna be about
infinity what is infinity and before we
can get there as an introduction I have
a couple of comments that I want to
address okay and I think they're
important comments both of them so here
it goes the first one I'd get it up
there there it is says this gentleman
says since only objects can have
location why can't an object and just be
defined as that which has location
Sandra
reasonable for example the triangle is a
shape but is also a concept and not an
object because it has no location okay
on the other hand if the definition were
that which has location it would still
be an object and it exists
because it has location whereas the
concept does not exist
this way anything without location is a
concept and anything with location is an
object
thus you eliminate the mention of shape
altogether sound traceable well not to
me
okay so let's see why it's not
reasonable why it's unreasonable okay so
let's look at that in the foundations of
physics we have to maintain a certain
order of definitions you can't just
define words in any old matter in a way
you can't put matter for example first
and start defining matter then work your
way towards exists or whatever or you
can't put exist first or motion first
specially motion now you have to define
them in this order this specific order
not only are these words cinema known
you absolutely need to define these
words in physics which no one has in the
last 3,000 years but you have to define
them in that order
see I can't put location as a criterion
because we haven't defined location yet
I can't talk about location until I
first put an object in the location
remember physics is first and foremost
the study of objects okay so we need to
define we need to define the word object
first and foremost that's the first word
you need to define in physics you can't
avoid it you the the the idea is you
can't do physics without an object if
there's nothing in the universe you
can't do physics there's nothing to
study assuming you were the only object
it's just the eyes your mind or whatever
your god you're looking out there
there's nothing absolutely nothing and
what physics is occurring well what
phenomenon has occurred so the first
thing you need to define is the word
object you need to know what an object
is in physics because you can't do
physics without objects once you define
an object then you can you find the
other words you can define distance
because that's the separation between
two objects location is the set of set
of block distances
up there it's a set of distances okay
that means you need the object first
then you need to have the location okay
motion two or more locations of an
object etc etc so you need the word
object before you can do any of those
words that's one issue here's the other
issue and the other issue is that why we
chose shape and that's because it's the
only universal property attribute that
all objects have all objects have shape
see touch invokes another object mass in
books and other object mass is a dynamic
word some people think it's the quantity
of mass of matter that's what they've
been taught in high school well that's
been overthrown so if that's the idea
you have you better to some research
because that's not the definition of
mass and anyway this mass is something
you determined through weight
measuring kilograms you put it on a
scale so it's a dynamic concept in that
sense volume same thing it's the region
occupied by an object etc etc all those
are either either require another object
that means you you you've got a circular
definition need an object to define an
object okay you need to objects in most
cases others think it's just the subject
of a sentence etc or something you can
talk about there's different notions of
what object is the only one applicable
is shake and that's why location doesn't
cut it and the other thing about
location is that you know not all
objects have location as he will said
you know there are objects like
triangles which have shaped but no
location and so we just say that those
are objects that do not exist because
exist is object plus location now you
need to have location in order to exist
so if god wants to exist he knows what
he's got to do he's got to not only be
an object he can't be love or
intelligence he's got to have location
as well with respect to the remaining
matter
and people try to put them beyond your
mind and they put them on the fourth
dimension or the fifth dimension or the
26th dimension is well God's outside of
the University I don't care you put them
anywhere you want there's got to be a
straight line from God to me no matter
what he can't escape that straight line
no matter where he stands in the
universe
and you can go out and discuss on your
own but that's that's the argument the
argument is there's a straight line from
God to me and if there is then he exists
and if there is no distance between his
chest and mine
God does not exist period by definition
not because I believe or don't believe
or whatever okay so here's a second
comment you don't wanna address in which
deals with subject matter of today it's
got to do with infinity visitor says
infinity is a valid mathematical concept
okay it indicates mathematical sequences
that have no heart stop okay okay take a
sequence such as all the natural numbers
you can list lots of them but at some
point you have to stop right you you
count to a hundred you get tired you
know that's all you did all day eight
hours you counted to 100 well you know
you can go to 101 but you stopped at a
hundred and you know that the numbers
continue that's what he's saying you
okay you can list lots of them but at
some point you have to stop but no
matter which number you stop that there
is the potential to have identified more
natural numbers the natural numbers do
not run out just because you stopped
listing them okay okay when infinity
validly indicates is the potential to
progress in sequences no matter where
you stopped in that case lots of
sequences are infinite infinity merely
indicates that when progressing in some
sequences you have to stop at some point
but the sequence does not run out of
terms you have to have you have you you
had have kept going if if you had have
kept going you could have found more
terms and he says it has a place in
science at least in the science of
mathematics
so the first thing showing addresses
that last one day mathematics is not a
science mathematics has nothing at all
to do with science let's get that
straight up front okay
people think that math has something to
do with physics with science that it is
a science in itself no it's not a
science okay
math is a language it's Chinese a
science is Russian Scientologists are
those Sciences no there's just languages
and mathematics is a quantitative
language of adverbs exclusively of
adverse quantitative adverse it doesn't
deal with adjectives it doesn't deal
with objects even though that it talks
about mathematical objects no they're
not objects none for the purposes of
reality physics etc so so mathematics is
a quantitative language it's a language
of quantitative adverbs it only
describes motion or qualifies motion or
modifies motion that's all it does
that's all that mathematics does doesn't
do anything else take any equation all
it's doing is describing some kind of
motion avenger that's what it is it's
giving you the location of a point or or
a value that's all it is and so so what
happens you can't have you can't have
mathematics be a science because it's
just the language that's the first issue
the second issue it's our method it's a
mathematics is a language that can only
describe and science is not about
describing science is about explaining
that's where we differ
okay listening with a mathematical
establishment so so here's the definite
the scientific definition of science
okay and here you have it done in
comparison and it's rational
explanations okay and physics is the
rational explanations of phenomena and
we require objects because we're gonna
explain causes and mechanisms and where
do we put not math because math is a
language where we put irrational
theories
is under religion and that includes all
of mathematical physics everything done
since the Greeks - today - Stephen
Hawking and beyond mathematical physics
only has irrational explanations for the
everyday phenomena you know the moon
going around the earth earth going
around the Sun they tell you to arch
space then they tell you in quantum
mechanics under the world of a small
their particle can be at two places at
once
all those are irrational theories I
don't care how they want to twist it and
turn into irrational theories and they
belong in religion so that's where we
put all of mathematical physics not
mathematics mathematics is a language of
symbols day of adverbs that's one thing
the conclusions of physical
interpretations that the mathematician
derive from their equations which they
purport to explain causes and mechanisms
of how this universe actually works
that's where we get into rationality
that's what we attack here okay we're
not interested in math we're interested
in attacking the physical
interpretations of mathematical physics
specifically a quantum mechanics and
general relativity okay and all we have
to look at is some of the definitions
that we looked at the other day that we
find out there for science and we find
out that there is no definition of the
word science as of today not an official
one they have all these things that we
discovered discussed the other day I'm
not going to go over that again but just
quickly it's not a study and one source
says observation experiment the other
one says testable explanations and
predictions so they have all these
notions and nobody knows what it's like
science is everything they never had a
definition of the word science and
that's why we're in a mess today and you
know this gentleman who wrote he's got
to begin there he can't escape the word
science can't say well this is what we
always thought about scientists what we
were told and this is you know this is
like saying that you know Christianity
is correct because you know 90% of the
world believes in it or
maybe 90s I'm a little over there maybe
30% or whatever of the world believes in
Christianity or in God and whatever
should we accept that simply because
most people believe in it is this a
democratic type of thing where we all
raise our hands and vote is that how we
decide what science is now you have to
fight for your definitions that's how
you do it if you don't have a rational
definition like no one has today for the
word science that's where we should
start we can't skip that step that's the
starting point you need to define
science ok so right now we don't have a
definition of science I've defined it
rational explanation it's very simple
you don't like it give me a definition
to oppose it to contrast against that
and see if you can defend it and I'm
sure you're gonna have a tough time
you're just gonna be defending your
religion okay and just in case of
physics right we have good old
Aristotle's definition okay we went over
that the other day but let's go over
real quickly what this physics means
essentially the study of nature that's
what the word physics essentially meant
or somewhere along those lines maybe the
translation is not perfect who knows but
what was it what was he referring to of
things that exist yeah that's the that's
physics physics deals with what exists
out there and what happens out there
that's what you got to explain nothing
to do it all with mathematics
mathematics has no business and to read
physics because math cannot explain what
exists okay so that's where the problem
comes and so you know and yeah it's the
study of nature and the study of nature
means that we are gonna figure out what
exists out there how mother nature does
her stuff that's what physics is and
what they did in the 17th century they
gradually from that point on
specifically it already came before them
but from that point on specifically they
started drifting more and more into
mathematics into abstractions and they
ended up with a nonsense of quantum
mechanics and general relativity and
what is what is the problem with that
with that is that they say well we ran a
test we didn't see because we can't see
these invisible things and these are the
conclusions we have but see the problem
is they simulated whatever they saw or
whatever they didn't see they simulate
everything with particles that's the
problem the problem is particles the
particle hypothesis has to die
we can't explain a single phenomena in
the universe with particles and it's the
particle people who are in the way they
should get out of science they have no
place in science anymore if you haven't
figured out after ten thousand years
that you cannot explain a single
phenomena of nature with particles then
you got a problem yeah you need to see a
psychiatrist that's what I think I mean
you know you got the force of coal and
they can't explain it with particles so
what they do they explain it through
pressure you know you remove whatever's
between two objects of the particles on
the outside push them in or something
along those lines quantum mechanics has
anymore more abstract they say you know
when one thing throws one object throws
negative motion negative momentum to
another and that's how it draws it you
know you send negative motion and
instead of hitting you and pushing you
away it draws you in because it's got
negative motion oh you do this put a
negative sign in your equation and
you're done but the question is whether
they can do that in the lab they can
show that that negative sign in the lab
okay so what's the subject matter today
it's infinity yeah just like this
introduction we just had and we started
last week with Middlebury Aristotle and
you yeah Euclid Euclid came a little
later than Aristotle he was the next
generation but they were working on two
different things
Aristotle was working on physics he was
trying to figure out you know motion
time he was analyzing distance those
sort of things
Euclid he was working on different kinds
of nouns he was working on geometry and
so even you know
they had these differences they applied
all these adjectives and qualifiers and
adverts to different announced to
different situations to a different
realm but what they both used is the
notion of infinity and that was uh quite
prominent among the Greeks they all
dabbled in infinity and one of the
issues was you know whether the universe
wasn't fitting in whether it was beyond
the Mount Olympus the gods out there
whether that was infinite you know so
you know the ether or
not only the quantity of particles but
the ether as a volume was it infinite
you know these questions popped in their
minds it since it was beyond their
capability of understanding all that
they just said infinite so what is
infinite infinite is the or infinity
infinity is an adjective that the
mathematicians have converted into a
noun that's what it is they've morphed
it into him noun so you know you have an
infinite series and you go to the end of
the series if you can or just keep going
and wherever you are you're that's
infinity that's aware that's what
infinity is even if you talk about the
infinite universe infinite space you're
talking about you're talking about being
at the edge you know of whatever's
growing out there you can't see the edge
because it's infinite right because
otherwise you would be able to draw an
object right and again the word infinite
is a violation of the definition of the
word object there is no object that is
infinite because an object is that which
a shape and now we do have a problem
where the word infinite because an
infinite is an oxymoron you know you're
you're saying that the object has shape
but it's infinite meaning you can't
imagine its shape and that's where the
contradiction comes with the word
infinite should never be used in science
infinite um belongs to mathematics and
the context is what numbers but it goes
a little beyond that that's what we're
going to look at here we have Euclid's
in notion of infinity he puts it in
elements okay and you go in then you
look at the
proposition 20 in book 9 is prime
numbers are more than any assigned
multitude of prime numbers and that's
the notion of this what this fellow said
earlier he said the sequence does not
run out of terms if you had have if you
had have kept going you could have found
more terms in other words you can always
add 1 to whatever number that you ended
up with and you can continue adding 1 +
1 + 1 + 101 never end
danni integers is is one of the
so-called infinite series and so this is
what Euclid was referring to and as
we'll see in a minute with Aristotle is
known as potential infinity and another
notion a little unrelated but more
related to what you clue was trying to
explain out there it has to do with this
with the fact that he defined a line for
example as an infinite geometric figure
if you can think of it like that I mean
I can't imagine how a geometric figure
figure being that which has shape
synonym of object how it can be infinite
but here's one of the objects that he
made infinite okay and he just made the
line grow and he needed that because
when he had a triangle for example if he
wanted to calculate an angle what he did
he would just extend the line and look
at the angle on the outside that's how
he figured out a lot of these things
that's how the grease handled the
situation
they looked out they looked at angles
outside of the triangle to figure out
things about the inside of a triangle
okay and so he says in his proposition
12 in this book 1 he says to draw a
straight line perpendicular to a given
infinite straight line from a given
point on it ok the Greeks just like we
have today they had this notion that a
line was infinite see that the line they
always draw it for you on the board
I never seen an infinite line you know
not a teacher has ever drawn an infinite
line for me it's always a
nine segments what is known as a line
segment and and so with the bricks that
they made their line infinite okay in
other words it just kept going and going
going
whatever that means because you know
it's like whoa I mean where does it stop
is it a geometric figure how do you know
it's a line if you haven't seen the
whole thing see you a line segment you
see the whole thing you say okay that's
a line which is really a line segment
formally right but when you look at an
infinite line one that is I guess
growing or God is putting more points
ever at the end of it in either
direction well then what sense does it
make what is that how do you know it's a
line because you haven't gone to the
edge to do to the border to the end so
you can't in for sure that that doesn't
qualify as a geometric figure because a
figure is that which has boundaries and
so we got a comment we got a
contradiction there and you know that's
the foundation of geometry laid down by
the Greeks and that's what we learned by
rote at school these days and that's
what all these mathematicians
mathematicians that's what they
subscribe to so you talk to them they
say oh yeah the infinite line and for
them it's just no problem it's like it
doesn't matter to them right okay Airy
Aristotle he applied infinity to a
different set of topics okay he was into
something else he was trying to explain
at least in primary and physic but also
in metaphysics his other book if there
is maybe they just came from his
students at the Lyceum but he applied it
to shape and form a number of existence
one of the things you know like if you
can assuming the ether is made out of
particles night let's let's assume that
for a second how many particles are
there is it it infinite and infinite
number you know I mean how many do we
count all these particles and saying
there's a billion or quadrillion a
gazillion and you know is if its
gazillion you got a fixed number you
know whatever
one with a bunch of zeros but if it's
infinite then those zeros keep adding up
okay so you got to determine whether the
number of existence is fixed okay so he
this is what he applied the notion of
infinity this is what he's gonna be
talking about whether you're gonna be
arguing for he's gonna justify it okay
obviously you uploaded the numbers
you applied it to the heavens you know a
space infinite you know its space the
universe are the heavens infinite and
here we have a little problem with that
because you know you're treating space
as a physical object or the universe as
you will let's look at space first
you're treating spaces as a volume as a
box as a balloon any way you imagine it
your dream is on a body of water the
cosmic ocean as Sagan used to say are we
is space a physical entity and if it's a
physical entity you have to tell me
what's on the outside you have to label
that on the outside and know you know
you don't have to go to the edge of
space for that no this is a conceptual
issue you got to drink a beer sit back
and just visualize it for me and label
it tell me what's outside of space what
gives contours of space and this is
where Aristotle you know more or less
had a problem right because they they
kind of said well it's infinite and they
just left that at that that you know
like let's not talk about it because
there's nothing like they say today we
have no way of proving it you know we
have no way of going out there and
finding out what's on the outside of
space and so they made space infinite
and they solve the problem in us it's
infinite so no more questions okay
that's that's how they handle it and
that's how they still handle it today
and now this is a conceptual issue
because your space is as we say nothing
then you then space in which nothing is
the opposite of something something is
that which has shape nothing is that
which doesn't now we can use the terms
consistently because they are antonyms
they are opposites and so if space is
nothing then space cannot be infinite
even if it were an object if it were an
object you had
infinite object and if it's not an
object you cannot talk about an infinite
concept not in physical terms so it
doesn't make sense to say that space is
infinite or the universe the universe
creates a second problem because now
we're talking about also you know the
number of existence in other words let's
assume there are particles out there yay
not only planets and gases and whatever
is out there that we can see but also
that which we can't see let's say space
is made out of particles as the ether is
essentially are saying so the question
there is again are those particles
infinite in the notice that they stretch
forever and this is not an issue of
going out there improving it with an
experiment this is a yummy conceptual
issue if you say that it's infinite okay
then it's not an object because all
objects are have shape you should be
able to draw space if space is finite if
it's in if it's infinite it contradicts
the definition of object and if it's
finite you gotta tell me what's on the
other side of it
you gotta label that what is it thought
that encompasses and encapsulates space
so these are the the issues you get
resolved that because these are
conceptual issues you don't go out there
and prove it with uh with your rocket
because before you do a design of it
before you do an experiment you got to
do a design of experiment you got to
conceptualize it on the board that's the
issue and and so yeah the issue is
whether the heavens you know these are
the topics of which he applied infinity
to or the notion of infinity motion is
motion infinite is time is time infinite
you know what do we mean by these things
and and here you have an example from
Aristotle's book where he used these
notions the notion applied the Infinity
apply test in regards to time and in
regards to time to motion motion in time
since everything that is in motion must
be moved by something he always had this
mover idæan is the back of his mind
right let us take the case in which a
thing is in the locomotion and is moved
by something that is itself in motion
and that again is moved by something
else that is in motion and that by
something else
and so on and continuing then the series
cannot go on to infinity but there must
be some first movement in other words he
is saying he's gonna analyze whether
motion is infinite and whether you need
a mover because if the original mover it
will call the Alpha okay that's the guy
or whatever that set things in motion
because until then there was no motion
he's asking what moved him but even
assuming that he had no need for
something to move him or it right then
the question is then you don't have
infinity in that direction you have a
starting point okay so you got a look at
these because these are conceptual
issues okay the other topic he applied
it to his time he says let us further
take the time in which a has completed
its motion and let it be represented by
K then since the motion of a is finite
the time will also be finite but since
the movements and the things moved are
infinite the motion ezh o in other words
the motion that is composed of all the
individual motions must be infinite so
this is what he was talking about
nothing related to geometry as in the
case of Euclid okay now why did why did
Airy bring these things up or what was
he after okay that's that's what you got
to try to you know look at the context
here okay and he wanted he he wanted to
attack or or challenge the notions by
the eally Attucks
okay let me get to that in a second let
me first say that what area did as a
result of this he applied
[Music]
infinity to several concepts as we just
discussed but the issue is he came up
with two notions one is the potential
infinity which is what this other fellow
just discussed and the other one which
is a little bit harder to understand
which is the actual infinity and
potential infinity is is pretty easy to
to graph okay if you can add another
number then you know you'll just go be
counting forever and I call it incessant
counting okay
County numbers incessantly but the other
notion which a little more difficult to
grasp in which very few people really
talk about is this other notion that
airy had which is actual infinity what
does he mean by actual infinity well
here you have a Venn diagram for those
of you who are familiar with that and
you're going to put the integers in
there so by definition the integers are
a complete system okay so within that
system he's he says you know there is an
actual infinity but it's not real in the
sense that you know you can't go to the
last number that's sort of thing and to
understand this concept a little better
of what I did was put a different
example which i think is gonna put it in
a better light for you and this is this
is my example okay let me put it over
here get rid of little area here okay
and what is it it goes like this
imagine you have a line segment not a
line not the infinite line we're talking
about a line segment so what does that
mean it means that you've got a fixed
line and we're talking about geometric
line we're gonna consider it one
dimension or whatever they want okay it
doesn't matter
we got a line and a line seven sorry and
we're gonna end the question is that's a
complete system because you got the
whole system within the Venn diagram so
it's all there oh all that I'm going to
talk about the line segment it's already
there completed from A to B from one end
to the other so you have the complete
system there now I ask you how many
locations are there on that line how
many points points is a location right
that
sort of thing and now you have an
infinite number of locations to use that
term okay in other words you can count
incessantly other locations and between
any two locations there's another
location and between any other - there's
another location so you have an infinite
to use their term right set of locations
for a fixed system for a completed
system that's the notion of actual
infinity okay that that these people are
trying to get to you so I hope that
helps you visualize a little bit of what
they mean when they say actual infinity
okay okay so Airy use this to attack the
yield addict he why because the eleatic
were said there is no motion motion is
an illusion there is no such thing as
most what are you saying
yeah that's what Parmenides and Zeno
were probably the most famous of the
addicts said there is no such thing as
motion motion is an illusion okay and I
showed this in a previous lecture in
which we had Democritus and his atom is
an ace and he believed there was motion
he said there is motion you move and I
do it with the 15-hour 16 square puzzle
right and he said yeah there is motion
see you move one and another one moves
and that's later in that place okay
and so there is motion because there is
a space in which something can move the
Atlantic said you know there is no such
thing as free space and so they they
said you know there is no way that you
can move one of these little numbers to
a space because there is no open space
and Aristotle and people like Descartes
who followed him in this notion said
yeah there is space but see it's
immediately taken up by another square
okay so this was their their their
differences in the way they perceived
motion this is what they were going to
talk about okay so so we have the ill
the addicts and they said there is no
such
as motion and Aristotle says you get
wrong there is motion except that
something feels that space immediately
and this was used by people like
Descartes Thomas Hobbes we're talking
about 17th century here Thomas Hobbes
who else they card Thomas Hobbes a few
others don't come to mind right now but
they criticized this notion that
Torricelli's had that he said he created
a vacuum okay and I showed that the
other day where people like Robert Boyle
and Gary King the German guy who created
vacuum there in his double hemisphere
copper double hemisphere they created
this thing which they said was vacuum
and which was the top in this case in
the case of Tortelli the top part of the
little test tube there the upside down
tusks - okay and they said look that
little space up there
that's vacuum okay and that's why the
water can't continue flowing up there
because it stopped by vacuum and and
what people like Descartes and Thomas
Hobbes who follow Aristotle in this
sense they said no notice something
fills that space you're being fooled
you're deluded
because yeah you remove the real matter
let's assume air water whatever from
that area from that volume but through
the inner spaces of the crystal
structures or whatever that you had in
there yeah
ether flowing in so you have the ether
filling in that vacuum and you do never
have total vacuum you have all these
little particles that we can't see they
called it ether and they said well
that's filling the vacuum and so this
was an issue this was an issue whether
whether there is motion whether you know
whether there are infinite particles and
if we're swamped by particles as soon as
you remove the visible or big particles
the little particles fill in the space
these were the issues that
people discussed intergenerationally
okay okay so where do we go from here
well here was here's the most famous of
Zeno's paradoxes I guess a lot of you
heard of them the Achilles and the
tortoise and what it is is that you know
Zeno runs half you know the the tortoise
has say 100 meter advantage over
Achilles so in order for the Achilles to
catch up with the turtle according to
Zeno he had to run first half of the way
and by this time the turtle went a
little further maybe two more meters
then Achilles had to run half that
distance the 50 meters plus the two now
he's got to run 26 meters okay so now
the turtle goes another 1 meter and now
he's got and now Achilles has to run
half that distance and so on so Achilles
knee never reaches the turtle that was
Zeno's point and he's and from this he
tried to prove that there was no motion
that was the note the idea that the
eleatic had and another notion another
paradox from Zeno which is probably just
as famous as the flying arrow and this
is how it was handled you Aristotle
talks about it in his book physics ok
now book six so the flying arrows Eno's
argument I summarize this ok and there
is no motion within an instant of time
right time is comprised of instance
right we have all these instants and
there's no motion in one of those
instants therefore there is no motion
because if you take no motion no motion
no motion the motion get the series of
no motions well you end up with no
[ __ ] that was Zeno's argument ok so
what does Aristotle says say to that he
challenges that notion of infinity
because again this has to do all with
infinity you know they're saying if
there are no spaces they're not infinite
spaces to fill then there is no motion
that was the early attics and Aristotle
says though the flying arrows
rest which result follows from the
assumption that time is composed of
moments if this assumption is not
granted the conclusion will not follow
okay so he's saying his time composed
the moments this is the this is what
Aristotle is challenging so he's saying
if there is no if time is not made of
motions then Zeno's paradox dies right
there okay that's it that's that's
that's his argument what is my argument
rational physics argument we have a
better argument today and we throw what
Aristotle say down the drain you say
look motion two or more locations
location is a static concept okay
location can only be depicted in one
frame of the universal movie shown below
okay just a little film strip of it in
that frame there is no motion so you see
the arrow and it's standing still in
each one of those locations in each one
of those frames of the universal movies
in each cross-section of time so to
speak which cannot be or you can call it
a moment if you want no problem you can
call it whatever you want but my point
is you need but you can't really call it
an instant because an instant of time
requires more than one frame no matter
what time requires at least two frames
you same as motion motion requires two
frames and so what they're confused here
is the notion of location location is a
static concept and for look you can
think of locations a photograph and
motion and time as a movie so the arrow
is static is standing still in each one
of those frames okay so there if there
is no motion within the frame in order
to see the arrow move you got to see the
movie you got to watch the entire movie
you got to have more than one frame of
the Universal movie and that's our
counter argument too
to Zeno's paradox in what Aristotle
proposed which is essentially what the
mathematicians today are you okay so
here we have some of the notions that
infinity have some of the mathematicians
developed notions of infinity to
ridiculous levels and one of the prime
guys for that was your Cantor he was a
German mathematician spent I guess half
his life in a loony asylum and you'll
see why because he he just overworked
his head on this issue of infinity
nonsense that mathematicians worry about
which has no bearing whatsoever in
science okay
and what you're George I guess he
identified three types of infinity he
says the infinity of God and again the
issue there is where the goddess is a
physical object that he's saying that
he's so bloated that you can't see his
the edges of God I don't know what what
he means by infinity of God we talking
about God's omniscience you know his
intelligence are we talking about or
knowledge are we talking about
he and being everywhere what are we
talking about when we say God is
infinite well what does what sense does
that make
we saying that God Himself is infinity
we're in his we live in his stomach or
something I mean what is this the
infinity of reality and there he tried
to give the notion that the items in
nature you know the the like the
elements that we talked about a little
while ago the elements he said could be
infinite because there are other worlds
out there and they have elements as well
and so I guess he saw the universe has
never-ending and so there's all kinds of
matter out there and all of that is
simply uncountable and therefore it is
infinite the infinity of reality that
was I guess his notion
and then the other one which is the one
here then it is that transfinite numbers
and sets of mathematics he he he didn't
like to I guess he didn't like to call
it infinite so he called it transfinite
he's the first guy in that trance and so
you came up with the transfinite
Cardinals used to quantify the size of
fight of an infinite set and transfinite
ordinals used to provide an ordering of
infinite sets none of that has any
bearing on science on physics I don't
know why you wasted his time the way we
look at it in science in rational
science there's really three notions or
three applications for infinity at least
three maybe there's some other and here
here you'll see them I synthesized them
the active infinite morphed into now the
known infinity okay becomes a place
somewhere okay so we have no use for it
in science or in physics at all the word
infinite should be wiped out for from
the history books from science from
everywhere keep it within math if they
have any use for it okay counting
incessantly you count Count count that's
more or less the notion of this
potential infinity you just count and
Counting and when you get tired you know
you you're gonna continue counting
tomorrow because that's your job to
count numbers okay so you keep counting
and take off where you left the day
before and you count incessantly that's
one on one notion okay of infinity and
again that's applicable solely to math
has nothing at all to do with physics
okay there's no real physical purpose
for the word infinite or infinity moving
constantly this is the different type of
notion somewhat related because counting
incessantly you're you're doing motion
as well right but here we're talking
about moving motion you're not counting
you're just moving and it's known as
perpetual motion and the question is
whether there is perpetual motion under
the Rope model I would say there is
perpetual motion there there's only one
perpetual motion and ask the universe
okay there's a single thread that
underlies all matter and this thread is
eternal in both directions of time it
never had a beginning it was never
created it will never die or stop movie
and so the in its end the universe if
we're going to use that term it's a
concept but the universe is a closed
system space which is nothing and matter
which cannot cross the line of that
which doesn't have a line which doesn't
have a border so matter has no way of
escaping space because there is no
border to escape not even God can escape
that which has no borders okay so space
does not allow matter to leave because
there is no such thing of space that's
why it's not an enclosure it's not a
container that you can reach the edge
and see if how can I get to the other
side no such thing space does not exist
there is no such thing as space space is
nothing and we have this matter which is
a single thread that underlies all of
the universe and it's as floating there
with respect to each other atoms with
respect to atoms all made by this single
thread okay that's that's the notion
okay and so this boobs out forever when
we die when we're gone the universe will
continue all this matter in the universe
club will continue moving so in that
sense it's perpetual motion not because
it was set in motion at some point in
time but because something we cannot
imagine and that's that just like matter
had no moment of creation motion had no
kickstart it never started moving and
people have trouble with it with that no
it drives them nuts because they say oh
what are you saying yeah because we're
not used it's not part of our ordinary
experience but yeah that's that's what
we're proposing we're proposing that I
hate the same because my son doesn't
like that no [ __ ] it dries a mess but
there were people before us in the
universe you know we're not we're not
the first humans to appear or life
for that man to appear on earth in the
universe there were living things in
other planets gazillions of years ago
and before them there were people before
them gazillions of years ago and before
them there were people before them
gazillions of years ago as well so there
was no first human there was no first
life-form
and that's hard for people to grasp what
do you mean there was no starting point
no no no starting line where everything
got set into motion where objects were
created and suddenly started moving no
ok so this is a difficult concept to
grasp so let me say it again there's a
single thread this thread has moved on
forever it was not created and neither
was the motion with which it started ok
if God wants to be part of that thing
he's gotta have he's gotta be made out
of atoms he's gotta be made of that
thread otherwise he's not here ok and
people have a lot of trouble with that
because there is no room for God in the
single thread God is not even outside of
that because you know he would still
have distance with respect of me or
location know if God wants to be God
wants to exist he's got to be part of
the universe that's the only way we can
use the word God could exist
consistently anyways that's food for
thought for you there the other one is
the the third notion of infinity is
extending a line forever that's the
notion again of mathematics geometry in
this case and a cheat because again it's
a question of definition of what is a
line is a line distance is the line
representing motion is it representing
time what are you representing with this
so-called line that is infinite that it
stretches in both directions what are
you talking about are you talking about
geometric figure if it's a figure it
better be at least two dimensional line
is said to be one-dimensional so I can't
even draw it I drew a two dimensional
line a plane that's what I do
and it continues he eternally if it
grows which is the notion that geometry
wants to give you you know that the line
extends and nobody asks any questions
and what are we talking about what is
this line this is magical line what are
you saying we're projecting a line just
to get an angle just to prove a theorem
is that the purpose of doing this and
again all that can stay within geometry
they want to play around with that with
this abstraction that's fine but keep it
within geometry don't tell me it's got
something to do with the real world out
there the real world we have to explain
mechanisms causes and what all these
people do with their infinity and their
geometric figures is talk about an
abstraction just to visualize relations
that's it it's got nothing to do with
explaining gravity for example or
electricity or whatever so so all these
abstract concepts should stay within
math and that's where infinity belongs
you in math they can talk about the
infinite series of numbers that's fine
as long as they keep it there it's fine
it's when they bring it into the real
world to say that space is infinite the
universe is infinite my love is infinite
that's where we get into trouble because
we're using the word in the wrong place
you know we're using you to apply it to
concepts and concepts cannot you can't
use an adjective to qualify a concept
not in physics may be an ordinary speech
you can but not in physics in physics
you can only apply adjectives to objects
so if you're getting use the word
infinite you're going to have to apply
to an object and there is no object that
is infinite that kills the word infinite
for the purposes of physics and science
anyways I'm going to continue analyzing
a little bit of Aristotle and Euclid and
we're gonna get into lines and from
lines wet to Plains we're gonna fly okay
so we'll see you on Sunday and hopefully
you'll come back we'll see you that bye
bye